apple released the airpods max over a
year ago in december of 2020 and when my
brother first bought his pair he let me
listen to them and i can tell you that i
was totally blown away by the sound
quality and now that we're in 2020 i
have finally caved and i bought my own
personal pair of airpods max so in this
video what i'm gonna do is explain why i
finally caved after so long and i'm
gonna share my experience and my review
over the past couple of weeks that have
owned these and then i'm going to
explain why i think i may have made a
mistake and why i might actually return
them but before we get into all of that
let's first start off with my story and
why i finally decided to buy these
airpods max now the first time i heard
them i really really wanted to buy them
but the problem was that we just spent a
bunch of money on remodeling my house so
i couldn't afford it back then and i've
been really craving it ever since then
but i could never justify the price
because i mean
550 dollars is a ton of money to give
for a pair of headphones and if you want
a completely honest reason for why i
finally bought these well there are
actually two of them first of all these
are finally on sale on amazon for a
really good price
479 dollars so it's definitely a good
discount and the second reason is that i
actually got a christmas bonus so i
could finally justify it because it's
kind of like a bonus with work and all
that so i finally bought these because
of the bonus but don't worry that's
actually not the only reason because the
recent reviews for the airpods max have
actually been getting a lot more
positive with people saying that the
reliability has been getting better the
software and even the sound quality
improvements themselves and new features
like the spatial audio with all of that
making for a much better product
compared to when these initially
launched so with that said let me
finally get into my experience in my
review of these after owning them for
the first couple of weeks well first of
all the sound quality is very very
impressive the base is good the highs
are good and it actually is better than
when i first heard them over a year ago
now on top of that the new spatial audio
feature works incredibly well and it
just blows my mind how it sounds like
you're in the room or you're in the
auditorium or in the studio with all the
sounds coming from different locations
around you and it's just so immersive
and to be honest it kind of gives for
like this emotional or kind of connected
listening experience which is what you
really want with headphones it kind of
like puts you in a different world it's
really weird but on top of that it also
works very very well with the apple
ecosystem like for example how i
connected them to my iphone and then
they were automatically connected on my
mac and it worked just so well with no
issues with switching from my iphone to
my mac it's just been so very reliable
and i'm very impressed with how good
these have been so everything from the
auto pause feature when you take them
off your head and put them back on it
works very well including all the
buttons the side button the digital
crown with changing the volume all of
that just works very reliably and i'm
very impressed by that but what really
surprised me was the battery life the
battery life on these things is
absolutely insane after i first unboxed
them i didn't plug them in for the first
couple of days and i was honestly
surprised that like wow these things are
lasting that long and in the past couple
of weeks i've literally only plugged
them in three times and that's not even
when they hit zero percent it was like
25 and then i would plug them in like
these things last forever but on top of
that the build quality is very very
solid so i don't even worry about
dropping these because there's no way
these would break you just got metal
everywhere compared to other plastic
headphones like in the past when i would
drop them and then it would crack and
unfortunately you got to buy a new pair
i literally do not think these will
crack if you drop them and then one
thing that absolutely blew my mind was
the performance of the noise
cancellation it just works
mind-blowingly well like you could play
some music have it on and you literally
can't hear anything around you but then
on the other hand the noise cancellation
is also very good for when you just want
to calm down and listen to some quiet
music with the noise cancellation
because you don't hear any background
noise and you just have some calm music
that's not at full blast so it just gets
rid of all of the background noise and
now because the noise cancellation is so
good almost like it's too good this
could actually cause a problem while i'm
at home because i do have a young son
he's almost two years old and if he
wakes up from a nap or maybe he falls or
something like that i won't be able to
hear him and thankfully there is the
transparency mode which is really really
awesome because the way it works is it
records your surroundings with the
microphones and then it plays them into
your ears while sounding incredibly
natural almost like you don't even have
anything on your head so with that said
i could just turn the volume up to
around 50 percent and still hear what's
going on in my house without worrying
about something happening so to sum up
my experience over the last couple weeks
i've got to say that i'm very very
impressed with the airpods max and i
don't regret spending that much money on
sale 480
on these headphones but unfortunately
with all of that said i think there's a
chance that i may have made a mistake by
buying them right now and i'm actually
considering returning them because of
something that happened last week let me
explain if you didn't already know mark
german is the most reliable apple leaker
out there and he was recently the guest
on mac rumor's new podcast where he
mentioned all the new products we should
be expecting from apple and one thing
that he mentioned was that we could
actually be seeing a new version of
airpods max with new colors later this
year yes this year now this shocked me
because i wasn't expecting a new version
until maybe next year 2023 but he thinks
it's coming this year and then on top of
that mark thinks that there's actually a
chance that the new version of the
airpods max could switch to a usbc port
instead of lightning which would
actually be a huge deal for a lot of the
people out there who are sick of having
the lightning port especially since the
chance that the upcoming iphone 14 pro
might come with a usbc port and if that
happens apple is probably going to get
rid of lightning across all their
products probably within a year or two
and finally mark says that we could
probably expect to see better battery
life on the new model as well and that
last point got me thinking because of a
recent video i made about the airpods
pro 2 coming with lossless audio support
and the way i think apple is going to do
this is by adopting their new ultra
wideband technology with the u1 chip
that they've been putting into every
iphone since the iphone 11 as well as
both the apple watch series 6 the 7 and
probably the upcoming eight and the
beauty of ultra wideband technology is
that it can potentially use 10 times
less battery life compared to bluetooth
as well as drastically reducing latency
close to as low as wired accessories and
of course it also offers massive amounts
of bandwidth up to
675 megabits per second compared to only
around two with bluetooth so with that
said i fully believe that the airpods
pro 2 are gonna have lossless support
just like mitraq claimed a couple of
weeks ago and i think that if apple
releases new airpods max later this year
then they're also gonna support ultra
wide band or whatever else apple adopts
to bring lossless and yes that means
that you're going to be able to play
high-resolution lossless apple music
with the next airpods max without any
wires and because of all of that i'm
starting to wonder if i made a mistake
by buying these airpods max over a year
after they came out and i'm wondering if
i should just return these right now and
wait for the new ones to come well in
reality there's a chance that they're
actually not going to come this year and
then that would be very unfortunate if i
returned these ones and now that i think
about it these have honestly been so
nice over the past couple of weeks that
i'm actually willing to lose some resale
value at the end of this year if new
ones do come out and i decided to
replace these with the new ones so with
all that said i've got to say that for
the full package that you're getting
especially having them work so reliably
with the apple ecosystem and of course
the awesome battery life i definitely
say that they're worth it for that sale
price of 479 on amazon and the really
solid build quality means that you could
keep them for the next 5 or maybe even
10 years if you don't really care about
new features like lossless supports and
that definitely makes these worth it so
there you guys go hopefully you enjoyed
the video and if you did go ahead and
click the circle above to subscribe and
definitely check out my airpods pro 2
lossless support video right over there
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next video
[Music]